[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
cell free tools to revolutionize the dna
construction paradigm
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by aura zero genomics to learn more
visit orizero.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
in addition to submitting questions
we request that you participate by
answering poll questions during the
webinar when prompted by our speakers
to submit your answer click on the
choice that best represents your answer
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
shige
genomics and kazu isuno global marketing
manager or ascerogenomics
shige and kazu you may now begin your
presentation
thank you mary okay let's get started
okay at first i'd like to introduce the
original original genomics company
so we are developing the unique cell
free plasmid dna engine and
amplification technology the company
technology is covered by six patent
family in the major market
and currently we have launched the two
of dna synthesis tools in the global
market you can buy it from everywhere
and also we are conducting the custom
service which can construct and amplify
up to 200 kb cytoplasmic dna
okay let's talk about current dna
chronic technology which is cell-based
cloning as everybody knows it this is
the e-coli system
but this cloning process has gone
largely unchanged for nearly 50 years
but as you know that the industry still
really rely heavily on the pcr and this
cell-based cloning system
also decay old methodologies and are
deeply rooted in effectively in the
whole aspect of biological research and
drug development
however they are not without
their limitation and drawback
okay this thread shows the key
challenges on the cell-based cloning i
think you may you may facing every day
so high gcl 80 contents and repeat
sequence cannot be amplified in equal
system
until its time consuming and multi-steps
and multi-day multi-day approaches is
required
and cytotoxic sequence is never working
and also its low throughput and the low
diversified diversity and difficulty
automated
and for manufacturing
its cell banking is required which is
time consuming and huge footprint of
facility is required
the good example is that the messenger
rna vaccine as well as therapeutic
antibody procurement 19 is increasing
reliance on the genetic material as
their engineering and technologies
now uh
i would like to introduce our original
cell-free plasmid dna technologies
original successfully um
thoroughly deconstituted into a single
reaction
based on more than 20 proteins which are
essential for e-coli general propagation
it has accurate self-reassembly and
amplification ability of cyclic dna
and solve the problem of pcl and
cell-based cloning
so there are three key features here so
first one is rapid because just a few
hours enzymatic reaction in that one
tube
and the second it's unlimited it is
applicable to any complex dna and
scalable to gram scale
efficient that carry out in the small
facility no need to large facility and
labors
okay before i move to the the more
detail our slides uh i'd like to have a
progression here so please take a time
to make an answer so what are you
struggling with equality based cloning
now
okay here we go let me check the uh
answer here
i'll still see people is
working i think
[Music]
oh that's interesting
okay now i can see that toppo is a g
series at such kind of difficult
sequence and uh followed by a large dna
construct
that's a very interesting result
okay
okay thank you for your answering then
okay now i passed the ball to the cas to
talk about more detail about technology
and data about our technologies
from here
i explain our technology
first step is preparing the dna fragment
to be chrome
this dna fragment can be pcl product
restriction enzyme cut or synthesized
dna
these and all c secants are joined
together to form the circular dna
rc is the replication origin of the
e-coli chromosome
therefore
the circular dna containing oc
becomes the e-coli
genome generic structure
and the protein involved in the
replication of the e coli genome enabled
this circular dna to be replicated and
amplified
circular dna design is simply place the
overall sequence at junction of the json
dna
design detail as explained in later
stride
by simply mix all the dna fragments just
compose the circular dna with assembly
reaction solution and incubate at this
isothermal condition for 30 minutes
it compare complete
the circular dna containing
the
orthy sequence
then this circular dna solution mixed
with
a protein cocktail which involved in
replication of e coli genome
and incubate also at the isothermal
temperature for two to six hours
only the circular circular dna will be
selectively amplified
and this amplification product can be
used in downstream application was
minimum purification
such as a
transfection
in this slide
it shows example of amplification
in the 8kb and 50kb amplification
example was only c
it can be seen that each circular dna is
amplified
in addition
amplification product becomes
supercoiled dna
if you want to test the exact length
it's recommended to treat the
amplification product with appropriate
destruction enzyme to make it linear
and analyze it by electrophrases
this slide shows the amplification
result of
base biased sequence
the left side is the result of surface
amplification of the 9.3 kb plasmid with
70 percent gc content
you can see that only the circular dna
containing odc is selectively amplified
on the right
is the result of the selfie
amplification of 7kb plasmid which has
approximately 80 percent of the ac
content
you can see the
supercoiled dna is also amplified here
in the lens 3
the nicked price meat and incorporate
amplification product are digested by
the small amount of action creating
super called the dna are remained
in this way
even if the sequence is generally
difficult to amplify
our self-regrowing technology can be
deduce the sequence selectivity
in this slide i will explain the
assembly reaction
here is the example of binding 10 dna
fragment with
600 base pair ranks
json fragments
such as dna fragment 1 and 2
have homologous sequence as fully base
pair at the junction
similarly designed to have overlap
sequence at the end
right two and three three and four
design is a similar to the gibson
assembly but overlap arrangement have
different lengths
in the assembly reaction
enzyme digest single strand from the
three prime end of the each dna fragment
to make a five prime product loading
and the complementary base anneal
at this time
our technique promotes the binding by
enzymatic
annealing instead of some chemical
annealing like pcl primer
therefore the reaction time of the
assembly was shortened to 30 minutes
on the right
it's a electrophoretic image of the
assembly product
the bound dna fragment appear in rather
pattern and you can finally observe up
to the desired
10 bounds
here is an example of connecting 50 dna
fragments and one odc to construct a
circular dna of 27 kb
the overlap between the json dna was
designed with 60 base pair
after a simple reaction
the product showed the latter appearance
of several dna fragments bound
together
also it cannot be seen here
51 dnas are finally assembled
a part of this product was mixed with
the amplification via the agent and the
amplified
when the amplified product was checked
by electrophrases
the target 27 kb supercoiled dna was
confirmed
the assembled product were used for the
amplification reaction
but it's also contained non-circular
dnase
but it doesn't matter
the template requirement
in the principle of amplification were
two
one is containing an rc sequence
the other is circular dna
so
even if it's a fragment containing
origin
it will not be amplified if it's not
circular
it's also in a feature of our technology
that we can select selectively amplify
only the full ranks construct without
purifying the assembled product
here we show the possibility of
application
upper one is an example of aav
application
as you know af we require multiple
plasmid
but you can cut out the gene region that
had the function you need
then integrated them into one vector
since e chori is not used
the antibiotics resistance gene had be
moved to create an
integrated construct
following is an example of entire genome
chronic
an adenovirus genome has
35 kv linear dna
so it converted into circular dna with
some
of c sequence
finally bottom 1 is an example of
amplifying 140 kv of a bacteriophilus
by inserting the oc sequence into the
circular dna
we could amplify 140kv
of vacuum bios gin
in this way
our technology has potential to be
applied to
various applications by allowing the
length of the chronable dna
unconventional technology
this ride is hot topic
this data is an example of cloning the
entire south cop2 genome in
collaboration with kyoto university in
japan
since saskop2 is a single surround rna
genome
it was designed by divided it into six
fragments with five kb cdnas
in other words
this construct is consisting seven
fragment which of six
cdna and one origin
in this way
the enter gene was amplified cell free
solid kv and
transfected into cultural cell for
genome analysis
practical applications like this have
already began
in general
at least sequences works against
amplification
but without self-re-amplification
technology the effect is relatively
small
we incorporate the synthesized 160 base
pair of fourier into 4.3 kb circular dna
with oc
then we compare the yield
the cell free amplified product were
analyzed by cutting the backbone of
circular dna by
destruction enzymes and electrophoresing
them as two linear dna
we can see the longer dna fragment as
common sites
but the shorter dna fragment has not
the poly fragment shows a higher
molecular weight as a
160 base sphere greater
first it was shown that even if the
sequence had the fourier sequence our
technology does not affect on
application
in this slide i mentioned yield
with the conventional large-scale
culture method by e-coli
it took time and effort
the most complicated task is to generate
plasmid dna from cultural e-coli
however
without technology
plasmid preparation can be completed
on the benchtop in short time
present our reagent generate one
microgram surface amplified dna in 10
microliter reaction
but
what should we do
if higher is our need
in-house experiment
we have found that there is a linear
correlation between the reaction size
and yield
in other words
one microliter reaction yields
0.1 milligram
and
1000 milliliter reaction is 100
milligram of amplified product
moreover
the reaction time is not much different
from present hour cat
i can suggest you the large-scale
plasmid prep as possible to reduce the
time drastically
of course
there is no need for large culture tank
so capital investment can be minimized
in
2023
we plan to start shipping this
large-scale cell free amplification
reagent
as gmp grade
this right has shown a technical
comparison for amplifying dna
the main dna amplification technique are
pcl
and e coli chronic
but there are some disadvantage at each
technique
for example in pcl
it's amplification ranks and fidelity of
the product
also in in korai
let's take the time to culture
our technology as new technology
just throw these problem
self-reamplification of dna up to 50 kb
in several hours
fidelity is
100 fold greater than pcl one
also
any difficult sequence are applicable
so we can say it's just the beginning of
the new generation of the cloning
technology
from here
we will explain about our current
product
two kits are
currently available
the first is the
original sell free cloning system
the kit that
creates amplified circular dna with
nobel oc construct
this kit contain five reaction of
assembly reagent and the 10 reaction of
amplification reagent
second is the original cell free
sweating system
nakitza allow you to introduce oric into
your existing prospect for selfie
amplification
this kit contained reagent for 5
reaction
finally
the rc amp kit contain
only the agent for amplifying circular
dna with
with orisi
this reagent is commonly included in the
original cell free crowning system and
the original cell free switching system
i introduced the outline of the product
of the switching system the armchair
from next strike
the explanation so far has been about
newly creating and amplifying the
circular dna using the original
cell-free cloning system
from now on
i would like to explain another reagent
or zero cell free switching system
this kit contains a dna fragment called
the ss oric cassette
this ss orc cassette has a homologous
sequence on commercially available
vector at the end of the oric sequence
this homologous sequence can be used to
introduce
an ss or c cassette into an existing
plasmid backed
by homologous decombination
after introduction
it can be used as a template for selfie
amplification
however
using the original cell free switching
system does not allow the rc
introduction into all vector
some of the popular plasmid described in
the table
can be introduced
because they have a common sequence in
their backbone
in case
there is no homologous sequence on your
back day
you can introduce receive with original
cell free cloning system
this homologous sequence is described in
the user manual so first check whether
the sequence is included in your vector
before using it
in addition
even if the homologous sequence
overlapped with gene region on
the sequence does not change due to
homologous recombination and
this gene is not
disrupted
here
the data in which the ssrc cassette is
inserted as shown
once
inserting
the
ssrc cassette total ranks elongate the
426 base pair which corresponding to the
rc sequence
in addition
this electrophoresis diagram show that
all c integrated dna show the stable
yield
as equal to
or higher than the
non-inserted circular dna of e coli
production
the rc applicant is for
self-re-amplification kit
it does not contain a symbol
reagent this kit can be amplified
already created a construct which
containing the oc
therefore it can maintain the construct
into
this eliminates the need to store
e cholera in glycerol's glycerol stroke
anymore and the tiny amount of oc
contain
the construct can be amplified in half
days
at any time
of course since e-coli is not used
purification of the amplified product is
easy
the reagent muscle makes including
include in this kit has optimized
enzyme and substrate on standard
protocol
therefore if all substrate in this
muscle mix is used
concentration
will be
109 grams per microliter and one
microgram yield
reagent kit are capable
of self-re-amplification
of circular dna up to
50 kb
and the yield is 10 microgram pocket
our kit have already been shipped more
than 700 kits since product rank
and the purpose of them can be roughly
divided
into four
there are
two chrono virus
four wrong dna chrome
for difficult to chrome which does not
grow well in
e coli
and
process enhancement
we are proud that our product have
answered to the customer's needs
so
what are the unmet needs
it can hear the voice of customers who
need longer
and larger amount of dna
these are not satisfied with the spec
specification of the the current kit
to meet their need
we can offer
custom service
in fact
our technology is possible to create the
construct up to about
200 kv
and it has been verified by in-house
experiments
larger amount of the yield can be
obtained by using the specialized enzyme
cocktail from commercially available kit
jejo
if you need
more length or even longer
than current care
please use this custom service
orizio genomex is a japanese company
headquartered ads in tokyo
also we have a u.s office in
massachusetts
in addition we have several contributors
in europe
and asia
and we have expanding our sales area all
over the world
for product inquiry
please contact us via our website or
email here
we will develop and launch the new
product continuously
thank you very much for attention
thank you shige and kazu for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for let's get started
our first question is
how short or long
can d how short or long of dna can be
amplified
okay so the short one is uh so our
system can be uh applicable from the 200
bb
and the large size so that you can
amplify
you can amplified up to 50 kb with the
cloning system and up to 200kb with in
our custom service
all right thank you
next question
what are the major differences between
ori zero assembly and gibson assembly
yeah i answered from my site so the uh
gibson assembly and the differentiation
of the gibson assembly and our our
assembly technology is so the gibson
assembly is just the thermal annealing
but uh so that our our our uh assembly
technique as
so the uh it's called the enzymatic uh
annealing
so the the uh so the on the on the
process of their nailing so the out in
in our technology so the sum of the the
special enzyme access to a nail
to increase the efficiency
all right thank you
next question
can the amplified dna be used for
transformation of e coli in transfection
of cultured cells
um let me read the question one more
time
can the amplified dna be used for
transformation of e coli and
transfection of cultured cells
yeah yeah
yes
go ahead cousin
yeah it's possible to use that
everything so that so the amplified dna
is just it's it's almost equivalent of
the
the
regular circular dna so it's possible
yeah
all right
next question
what should i pay attention to when
designing an assembly reaction
yep
so the assembly reaction
so uh i will
explain the
uh sort of some of the rules
so the uh
[Music]
so
so design ads as a
it's a required operat ranks
uh it's a 40 to 60 base pair it's a it's
a it's a require
so the shorter longer it's not not
especially the shorter ranks so that for
example the six or eight base pair
uh overlap it's not not applicable so
the require the 40 to 60 60 base pair
it's required it's a
attention point one
and the second one adds so the total
amount
so the uh you have to use the a few
picogram to up to the uh 29 gram
so the uh so the
amount range
should be within
a few gram to 29 gram
and the uh serving as a so the mixing
recipe is very important
so it's a it may i mean so the eco
uh eco moral rate is a very important
for example the uh or c
from uh and uh dna fragment should be
cocktailed
one one ratio
at the end of this one as a this is the
last one as a uh
so
so the uh
the to apprec
approximate the the dna length of the
fragment
so for example the 10 kb
dna construct
so the fragment
to use the two fragment
you should so the 5kb and 5kv 2 fragment
it's it's much better uh design
and uh
so the 3kv and the 7kv
or uh
it's it's not
not good design so this sim uh so that
approximate
the
the dna length it's very important this
four point is a it's a
good
rule of the dna design
all right
thank you
next question
what should i pay attention to when
inserting the ore c
fragment yeah
uh
so obviously uh inserting the oric
fragment just position as a
and
it's possible to insert the rc fragment
anywhere
so there is no restriction on the
insertion direction
so
all right thank you
next question what is the error rate for
the isothermal amplification step
um
error rate is a it's much greater than
the uh
pcl roughly the pcl it's about the uh
so our amplification our fidelity is
about the 100
fold greater than pcr
all right
and
our next question
what's
the oh i'm sorry excuse me we we are
running out of time for questions i
forgot that we have one more poll
question
that we would like the our audience to
answer
um if we could pull up that poll
question
what are you interested in orissero's
cell fleet cell free
cloning technology
transfection efficiency
dna cloning difficult by e coli
large plasma dna construct
poly a doesn't lost isn't lost
library preparation for maps
remember to select your answer click on
the option
that is the best choice for you
in our poll question what are you
interested in orissero's self-free
cloning technology
transfection efficiency
dna cloning difficult by e coli
large plasmid dna construct
poly a isn't lost
library preparation for maps
you have
a few more seconds to make your
selection and again click on the best
choice for your answer
thank you
and kazu do you have any final comments
for our audience
thank you
thank you very much for uh today's
attention um we really have uh happy to
have more christian
ask
if you can send
more questions to my email so um yeah
please briefly ask
to us
all right well thank you again shige and
kazu for your time today and your
important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor ori zero genomics for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you